there is recent frustration outrage is a
better word actually
about a creative choice by mapa with
attack on titan season 4.
i say creative choice because well
that's all it was
so-called fans of the show harassed mapa
studios and hiroyuki omine the creative
director of episode 5
because the music choice he used the
music choice
these people were so upset and so vocal
with their outrage that ominet was
forced to lock his twitter
and had to call for a direct statement
from mapa staff members
and it's all just very very
disappointing it's one of the few times
when i've been really saddened by the
anime community
even though we can be very split on
opinions at times to let it go as far as
harassing people
who are just producing content for us
under a really rigorous schedule
in the midst of a global pandemic is
just so sad
so if you didn't know during this scene
after watching it many fans wanted the
ost from season two to play
and i see their reason completely this
part i can justify
i mean it would have been poetic in a
way that the same osg used when reiner
shows air and he's a titan and betrays
him
is played back when aaron reciprocates
the action
it would be a nice callback to one of
the best moments in attack on titan so
far
easily but it's not like the music
choice on nominee's part was bad either
it was a similarly epic soundtrack and i
certainly felt hype watching the scene
honestly if people didn't bring it up i
never would have even thought of the ost
from season 2 to be used
an oil might probably be a slightly
better creative choice
i i can't understand degrading omni
because of that
and some people got extremely upset and
took to harassing him
and mappa for doing this along with the
criticism we're already seeing with fans
who are upset with the use of cg
it's terrible to see people making this
season come to fruition being criticized
for it
being an attack on titanfan has had its
ups and downs
i mean long time fans remembered the
four year wait we had between season one
and two
that was brutal and recently with a
surge in popularity
which i honestly didn't even think was
possible considering the show has been
massive since season one
the show has amassed a fan base that is
nothing short of monumental
many praise attack on titan for being
one of the best anime of this decade and
for the most part
fans are generally united and loving the
show
but recently it's got out of hand along
with this harassment of the director i
see fans who demean other anime for the
sake of praising attack on titan
on tiktok and twitter all the time and i
don't mean for this to represent a
majority of the fan base
nor do i even think it's a large number
of us for the most part we're just
people who enjoy good anime
but with a huge fan base there are bound
to be bad apples
and this is just proven with the recent
outrage mappa has had more than a full
play recently with the struggles of
kovid which
are prevalent everywhere as well as
having other huge blockbuster anime like
jiu-jitsu kaisen that they have to
handle every week
and they're on a time constraint i think
people who criticized the director
forgot to that the people making attack
on titan producing this entertainment
for them
are humans too and to degrade them in
such a way just for the sake of
justifying your own opinion
is cruel and disrespectful and the
statement from the staff member from
mapa basically said the same thing and
it's just terrible to see them have to
resort to this
you know a written message to please
stop harassing them and let them do
their jobs which they've already been
doing the best they can
i mean to address the gripes with cg
which is of course
upsetting to various degrees depending
on who you talk to
i don't think the anime fans publicly
criticizing the cg
understand how hard it is to make
animation like what wit studio did with
season 3 and before that even
and i think they're forgetting there
were holes in wit studio's animation as
well
when they even tried to do cg it ended
up looking like this
unless we're talking about ufotable
which is a company with just
unbelievably
incredible animation attack on titan in
the previous seasons is easily top tier
animation wise
but animation in itself is super hard to
do and takes a super long time with a
really big budget if you're gonna make
it look good
and once wit studio was no longer able
to maintain that the only studio that
was even willing to take on such a big
project
and fill such big shoes was mappa
cg is cheaper and easier and i don't
think it's anyone's preferred animation
style including the creators of the show
so it needs to be said that sometimes
they just have to do it
i don't think anyone really wants to
resort to cg it's a necessary evil
animation budgets and time allocations
aren't boundless and sometimes it needs
to be accepted which most fans have done
and done well one thing that i was
really happy to see was the
thank you mapa movement that we saw on
twitter after all the outrage
and this really shows what a true fandom
is what fans of an anime
really do to support the creators and to
show the love for the shows they love
i think this is a better representation
of attack on titan fans in general
or at least i would hope so and for
anyone who participated in this or
supported it i
do give thanks we can only hope to
improve and seeing this gave me hope
after seeing something that was very
depressing
i mean the people complaining across
social media surely aren't berserk fans
because then they would truly know the
struggles of having a bad adaptation
which
attack on titan is far from if anything
we should be grateful that mapa took on
the project
after whit couldn't do it and that
they've managed to make cg
look as good as it does something that
many shows fail to do
i've kind of gone on a rant here but
it's because you know as a long-time
member
of the anime community meeting friends
through it you know starting a youtube
channel that i devote dozens of hours to
because of it it's really saddening to
see people who can't accept anime for
what it is
it's a business with real people working
behind creating a product that they
always hope their fans will enjoy
to bring the director of an anime and
the staff members into your own
complaints and opinions
is honestly just super disappointing and
something that i hope the anime
community learns from and doesn't repeat
and i don't normally report the news or
recent real life events on my channel
but
i felt that as a primarily attack on
titanfocus channel it was only
appropriate
so sorry if this video wasn't as
entertaining as usual i mean
it is a pretty upsetting topic so i'm
not sure how entertaining i could even
make it if i wanted to
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
[Music]
analyses